how many dms have you had this week yo i
don't count them right and how many
people have stopped you this week
how many people have stopped thank you
very much you don't need to answer that
one she could count how many people have
stopped her but she can't count how many
videos
come on bro
instagram there's a guy in new york
that's messengers i've seen your
instagram like rob boom i got i got the
bentley there i got comply
there's a guy in uae that's saying oh
god
hold up
allow if you've asked the question allow
her to answer and then you'll you'll be
next to speak yeah
i'm not being funny but i'll i'll walk
down the street and i'll get attention
i'm sure it's the same for a lot of
people we'll get attention i go to the
gym i'll have guys approach me at the
gym come on i'll be in sainsbury's i'll
have someone approach me in sayings
please it's exactly the same thing you
can't stop someone from being approached
it's not their fault if someone comes up
to them approach them and it's exactly
the same with instagram and you need to
have that respect and trust that they're
not gonna
engage and not gonna act on it and
here's my here's my response to that are
you on inside the sainsbury's walking
with your bathing suit on
no but i'm on the beach with my babies
are all girls on this on the beach with
their bathing suit on instagram hold on
can i all right bro
[Music]
bro
okay so this this can't work because the
reason why i asked your question is for
you to think about something before i
lay my conclusion down if you're gonna
avoid what the obvious answer is then
it's not going to work i'm asking you do
most girls have revealing pictures on
instagram
i i don't know
that's a yes
thank you very much thank you very much
for being true
most girls have revealing pictures on
instagram you're not going to be walking
down to sainsbury's wearing the certain
pic
certain times i'll chirp scale to be
like listen let me see your instagram
boom ah is that what is that what the
thing saying yeah right cool boom all
right i could talk to you do you know
that instagram's not real life right all
right can i say my brother i know this
but i'm saying to you i'll be posting
stuff on instagram people think you know
you can't
girls can't avoid this bro because this
is their big this is their biggest this
is their biggest of um thing where they
get the most people that chirps that
where they get their most men from in
2022 and you what men are saying to them
listen you can't have that and they're
saying what later but i'm not taking
away
like my main option thing bro like and
i'm saying to you okay wow all right oh
you are you're on instagram on instagram
on instagram
on instagram
you should say earlier your instagram is
private it doesn't it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter that my instagram is
private it does mount no because i get
so many requests it doesn't mean i have
to let them in you get how many requests
a lot i have thank you very much there
you go yes
how many two over two thousand there you
go two thousand a minute it's not
stopping you that's wrong
yo yo hold on hold on can i ask my
question now cause i've been chilling
here for a little bit now i've been
patient i've been patient bro um but
what i'm saying is yeah first to double
back because we've we've gone a long way
um you started off your first question
to um kirsty was um would you think
you're cheated would you leave a
cheating bravo
the reason why i think she's like art is
um your in comparison is cheating um is
because you've already stated that a
narrative you've come in with a person
with a narrative he why is it not your
brother
would you leave your brother because if
you want to make the equivalent is would
you leave would you trust this person
your partner or because
as opposed to your brother now you're
saying this cheating on this um leaving
brother you've already put a narrative
on the guy from the jump yeah but he
hasn't stole from you yet no but you
still put a narrative under brother so
therefore wait wait wait therefore if
you want to put in comparison it has to
be equal you have to put a you now have
to put a narrative on this other partner
that you want to now deal with so it
being a cheat and thieving i don't know
killer
the other partner has to have a
narrative as well for it to be equal
number one number two is yeah
um this thing about you got with
instagram and you want to check about um
this whole instagram thing is that yo
like she said you gotta be you gotta be
realistic i hear what you're saying but
you're trying to have your cake and eat
it too like it's a mouth because you
said you you've moved to a girl you
you've moved to a girl knowing how she
is knowing what she's that's the game
wait wait it's the game you've commented
you've come into the wait wait wait let
me land let me land because i'm still in
the air this is how it is
um
you've come into it no one has respect
you've you've come into the game knowing
how she was in it yeah
fair enough when you come together
there's levels of compromisations but
you must also understand yeah wait you
don't do that
you want to also understand yeah
you want her to do a whole360
180 or 180
so that she can fit to your to your
standards is she going to be the same
person if you cut off all these
boundaries that you liked her for yes or
no is she going to be different because
she's not on instagram anymore is that
what you're saying yes or no yeah it's
what is she gonna be different be sad
it's not a hard question no no no sorry
girl is she gonna be different now that
she's not on instagram
she shouldn't be
thank you very much so she's no
different than she has an instagram or
she has an instagram menus
just listen to two minutes listen
we'll mention
a lot of minutes
would her man stool chirps would
menstrual chirps are on the street yes
right so she's right right so she's
still available right so why is it so
hard for you to get rid of your
instagram but things are inevitable
hold on bro
why is it so hard for you to get rid of
your instagram all right the real
question go on
i just told you like i've had my
instagram personally since i was 12. i
don't i don't use it as like a dating
platform that's why my page is private
because it's it's my life like what i
want on there i select who's on there i
select who's on there my family's on
there so now i can't contact my family
because i don't i don't text and call my
family every day you are trying to
pretend like i'm like you don't know
what i'm saying
there's a difference between uh there's
a difference between i sell pots and
pottery on my instagram and i didn't
wait hold on let me let me land let me
land there's a difference between
selling pots and pottery on instagram
and you have your instagram page there's
a difference between you have cats that
you post on instagram and dinner on your
page there's a difference between you
using your instagram to message your
family that you might know from a broad
and pain okay cool there's a difference
between that and you know what i am
talking about bro you know with the
advertisement the administration
online the advertisement of you online
okay that's what we're talking about
don't shift the goal post we're talking
about you the with the normal page where
you go in a certain gallery and be like
oh i've seen everything that's right
because you're attracting though that's
the type of girls you're going for if
you're going for it if she is she if
she's if she hasn't got that
know what comes with girls that
broadcast themselves in bathing suits if
you want a girl that doesn't want that
then go for a girl that doesn't do that
if she doesn't do that you won't have a
problem with her instagram and all right
and and the point that i would lead to
that is so has most girls got instagram
yes yes right so most girls have got it
anyway yeah so it's not like oh you
could just on the situation of oh you
know i'm saying you're on instagram or
you're not in on instagram we're talking
about people that are already on
instagram okay okay
i can combat that and then we're going
to do some chats after that
so you're saying that most female most
women are on instagram of course yes
speaking personally
if you if you're looking for someone
that
isn't
pro-trained that they're in the streets
my page my page does that i
portrays that i'm not in the street
sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry i'm sorry
my praise just portrays that i'm not for
the streets but
i ain't ugly by any means right so if
you're looking for somebody that um that
doesn't give you that feeling that oh
they're gonna have people slide into the
dms or they're gonna be talking to the
next man or however it is the reason the
reason why you don't want her on
instagram if that's something that you
don't want if she is portraying if the
way that she got you is the way she's
going to get the next man maybe you
shouldn't go for that woman yeah it
sounds like you're insecure
okay hey
i want to add something i don't i don't
think you're insecure i think um one
thing i will look at is
this really is dependent on the status
of the man if the man
is at a higher status in level of wealth
or in the top 15 to 20 percent of men
you'll find that he's going to find
girls that are more attractive these
girls will have a lot of options so then
it becomes one of those things where
he'll go okay cool
i'm gonna need you to delete your
instagram because the type of attention
you're going to create or get
is
well above the average woman
when we're talking about average p like
people like they're not gonna facilitate
this much attention where
the opportunity to cheat is so far